hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar easily upgrade your flow
cytometry data with brightfield images
using the attune sightpix flow cytometer
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
cora chatick technical director flow
cytometry at amsterdam umc
cora you may now begin your presentation
[Music]
hello and welcome my name is cora
chaddock i am the technical director at
the amsterdam university medical center
location vuemc
in the
molecular cell biology and immunology
department
we have a nice wide array of
instrumentation here in in our core
facility in at the south of amsterdam we
have uh mass cytometers standard
fluorescence cyclocytometers spectral
cytometers orders but what i've been
really excited about these days is our
opportunity to uh demo and do some
testing on the sitepix the new imaging
cytometer from thermofisher so this is
built on top of the attune nxt acoustic
flow
acoustic flow cytometer and i was uh
really excited to be able to add this
imaging function to and a tune because
our tune is one of the workhorses in the
lab the fluidics are very very stable it
just keeps running it's able to run
really large volumes so the sample line
is really easy to clean to reduce sample
carryover i just love this instrument we
have a
skin lab here that runs all these very
large cells that are adherent cell lines
and we can just clean out the system
really nicely so now i'm going to take
you over to the software and show you
the real power behind the system
okay so here we are at the software this
is how you after you've opened the
software and
run a startup and a performance test how
it would look
you see these modules for creating or
doing these qc tests and new experiments
importing an old experiment creating a
new experiment from templates and i want
to start a new experiment i could click
on new experiment but i'm going to use a
template that i want i know i want to
use for this demo i will open that up
and you'll see that i already have some
plots that i like to start out with are
standard for inside scatter and then a
couple of
doublet plots
um
i will be running three different colors
on the system today so two antibodies
and um
a live dead stain one will be in the uh
first detect on the first detector from
our blue laser and i don't like taking
the height or the width off of our color
parameters
and then also uh the first detector on
our red laser for a alexa floor
647 and then our live dead blue stain
and it's just easy as that to select the
parameters that you would actually
uh like to collect
and then once i come under this new tab
you can see we now are able to find the
voltages and that only the channels that
we've selected are available
when i can also play with the threshold
if you want to threshold out debris and
all of other all your other advanced
settings like
area scaling and window extension can
also be found here
so the next part i like to show is
the fact that
we also have these uh set volumes here
uh our set flow rates here and we can
use
any variable volume between 40
microliters to
uh four milliliters
so first i need to go and actually grab
an unstained here
and maybe uh also add some dot plots for
each of our color parameters in our nice
workspace
could also choose density precedence
density um and i will stay away from
histograms for now
and i am in
sample one as i would like to be i will
these windows are all modular too i can
kind of place them where i like so right
now i'm going to
bring my experiment browser over here so
i can have a better look at my sample
and my color channels
i will go ahead and click run so i can
start previewing what the sample looks
like
and there's our ford inside scatter
let's say our ford scatter is
a bit too low for these cells
and the really nice thing about the
software too is every time you change a
voltage you automatically get this uh
refresh in your data view
and side scatter looks good enough we're
looking at pbmcs today um
so you can uh see that that these are
nicely on scale for forward and side
scatter
um i think i would like this plot to
actually be a density plot and i'm going
to change the resolution it really is
just as easy as that in this customize
in this customization panel or in this
customization window now i need to look
at my color parameters so here's my live
dead channel
and then my cd3 and a
cd 14.
so now that i have my forward and side
scatter set i don't think i need to
play with change the area scaling at all
so i will go ahead and stop um this is a
syringe driven system so it has taken up
25 microliters um and i am able uh to
recover a portion of that if i like
either into the same tube or into a
different tube i'm going to recover into
the same tube
then i get my sample back um
and i am
able to
retain that remaining uh 71 microliters
for the most part there's a bit of
volume there too
so now i want to check my
full stain control and make sure
our positive signal
is also on scale
since i'm drawing 100 microliters and
running at 25 microliters per minute um
i have about four minutes to do all of
this setup which should be plenty of
time for three parameters
so here we can see that we have a really
nice uh cd14 staining um but our cd3
doesn't seem to be super strong but we
also have nice clear live dead staining
here
um i think i want to get a little bit
better separation on the live dead and
maybe i can do the same
with the cd14
which is on our red channel
i'll try 450 450 and 450. that sounds
nice
oh yeah that looks a little bit better
okay i have my setup here i also know
that i've looked at these samples
earlier and there's not great separation
with the cd3 i could zoom in here maybe
change the resolution and get a little
bit better view of that
but i'm not really sure about that
shoulder
so
um
i'm going to go ahead and stop this
again and
recover my sample again
and lower the tube
and let the sample alignments
so now
this is everything that i think most
people use used to seeing in a
standard
fluorescence flow cytometer um
and so uh yeah now we get on to the
really cool part um i've already done a
bit of calibration beforehand you can
see now i can come down to these image
capture settings um and so this is uh
something new that i think most of us at
a flossatometer are not used to seeing
um now we have some some captur some
image capture settings that we'll need
to play with so i know earlier i found
our focal plane
pretty well
this is our cd14 only stain
but i want to
find
the
correct focus for our flow rate and for
this sample and here you can already see
that we have some cells um i know some
of you are probably already saying ooh
and ah and wow at this point but of
course
it'll get even better once i find the
correct focus for these cells
so i'm going to run some more sample
again
imaging every event on all events
not set any image gates here so far so
as you saw with the last images we are
quite out of focus here
um so i'm going to
play in increments of 10 with our focus
um to see if it gets better or worse and
we can all agree that that is worse
let's go for 57 okay much closer
and if your sample rate is fast enough
you can usually see some preview so you
can see those are actually getting a
little more out of focus
so i'm going to continue further into
this focal plane
and if you weren't saying wow before i
know you're saying wow now
this was just i
during the very first training session
my uh my my jaw dropped um this uh this
region of interest on the camera so this
is our entire camera trip represented
over here we can select different areas
on our camera chip because it's a flow
cytometer the cells might not always be
in the exact same spot every single time
um
and so uh we just need to have a little
bit of flexibility um in that
positioning especially uh for our
illumination setting
um so if i want to maybe change the
contrast of these images a little bit
more i can also uh turn up or down the
illumination and also find different
points on um the camera chip that will
uh maybe give me a little bit more or
less uh
contrast in in our imaging here
if i try 80 that's going to be much
darker let's see
much heavier shadows on these cells
so these are uh illuminated with a 405
nanometer of four or five nanometer
laser
um let's go back up
oh way too bright yeah completely
saturated
so i think we were already and maybe
our sweet spot there whoop nope
45. there we go
48.
okay there we go again
i forgot momentarily uh where our range
was i uh inverted our numbers here went
from 84 to 48 instead
but we are back in action it goes that
quickly it is that it is really that
fast after you use the system a few
times to um find a nice uh focal plane
that you like and a nice uh imaging area
that you like as well playing with the
focus just a little bit more playing
around a little bit to see
if i might like one spot a little bit
better than another so i think on
average most of our images here that you
can see in the image gallery are maybe
skewing up and to the right
so i will simply um
move our region of interest for image
capture up and to the right so now we're
a lot more centered
with these cells
okay so i think i'm pretty happy with
these settings
maybe i could play around a little bit
more but for demo purposes i also want
to share with you a few other
experiments that we've done
especially with some larger cell types
where this becomes really exciting
but just to show a little bit more about
the uh capabilities of the system um you
have all of your normal stop options
that you would have on a flow cycometer
so let's say i want to record 50 000
um on our
p1 gate
on our r1 gate i should say
there we
go and i only want to record every 10
events out of that 50 000
and i only want to record events that
actually fall in that r1 gate because
i'm not particularly interested in
imaging debris
or what we assume is debris
okay so if i clear this i will
um
go ahead and record
i will likely stop this early because
we're running at 213 events per per
second um and i don't think i actually
want to wait for that 50 000 events
so now you'll see uh these images are
coming up a bit less frequently and
that's because i have our image capture
settings to that frequency of every 10
events
um
if you are collecting hundreds of
thousands or millions of cells you can
also have your total images be limited
as well and it also gives you a nice
estimate of how much
of your hard disk you'll actually be
taking up with those images
all right i will stop early again
i like having ten thousand that's enough
okay so we're at ten thousand um we
imaged almost a thousand cells which
makes sense if we're taking one image
for every ten cells that actually fall
in that r1 gate
um so that's how uh every day when i'm
setting up this uh
the experiments on the system it is
about 15 minutes from
uh initially powering everything on to
the moment that i am able to uh capture
images i think everyone in flow
cytometry uh
always enjoys uh the instant
gratification um in results that a flow
cytometer can give
this just takes it to the next level
really
another nice thing about this system
since it is a syringe driven
sample acquisition we can also uh just
to show a little bit more of the
capability of the instruments we can
also um see your uh concentration in
microliters um so this particular sample
um in our in our r1 gate it was almost
500 cells per microliter so it's nice
too you don't necessarily need to use uh
counting beads to find your your cell
concentration
so that's how quick it is to actually
set up an experiment
and so this is kind of our
if you're if you're on a cooking show um
this is the point where we've assembled
everything and put it in the oven um and
then uh
of course uh this would be our
our dish that we have pulled out of the
oven since i called it demo pre-baked
so this will look very familiar um but
in this system uh or in this layout i
can run
our full stain sample
even though i have switched experiments
um since the focus um of the camera
changes from day to day
uh our image capture settings have still
retained even though we have uh we've
fully changed
experiments
so i can let's slow down our flow rate
let's do 100 microliters per minute this
time
and have a little bit more of a
reasonable
amount of events that we want to capture
in this case
and we can create our r1 gate again
settings in this experiment are the same
as the ones that you saw in the previous
experiment
but i've already run all of our single
stain controls
um and we have compensation applied
to this experiment i can easily rename
my sample um just call this full stain
and what do we want to do this time
let's stick with that
r1 gate
and let's image
every 5 events
and this time i'm going to go with this
5000 for for our target actually i'm
going to image every event
and have our total images
target be 5000
come back to my collection panel and hit
record
there's our cells again see we're back
to the same settings
and i think uh we can all start
recognizing some different cell types in
our pvmc mix here
so we met our stop options and we've got
5000 images because we asked to have
5000 images and
all of them are loaded into
this imageview gallery over here
and you can see they're mostly singlets
but
uh we can also see
our
if i apply r1 here
let's take a look at our cd14 positive
cells
and you'll see in a moment why i keep
changing these uh gates from uh red view
to uh kind of more cool colors
rather than warm colors so now i can
select that r2 region
and here you go they should uh mostly be
macrophages
and if we are
curious as to where our
macrophages lie
on our dot plot
i think we should expect them to have a
higher forward inside scatter as we
would all expect
and if i go to a dot plot change the
resolution we can also come to our image
gallery
select a few images over here
if i hold the control button
right click and show selected images on
plots there we go
right up in in that
in that macrophage cloud where exactly
where we would expect them to be
um so that's how you're able to to view
images um there's also a
measurement tool
clear all images
here um where you can actually see the
uh size of each cell
and i am able to find the volume of our
cell and we can um or area of the cell
apologies and we can of course back
calculate to find the average diameter
and you also know the number of pixels
as well so um
measuring the the cell size is quite
easy on the system
and at this point i want to show off
some other experiments that we've been
able to run here
i will just bring this window over here
and tether it to this section of our
screen
um
this one is pretty cool it's uh we're
looking at uh
immature and mature dendritic cells
um so this is another user it wasn't
actively here when these are being
acquired but the images as you can see
are quite nice so these are our immature
dc's
and then i can come over to the
select the same sample with the same
staining our mature
dc's look at that
big hairball it's so cool
um maybe uh select a marker here let's
look at this r6 gate
yeah
just wow
just wow
um
and uh
kind of one of the the very first things
that we thought of doing at the system
was looking at um really really rare
populations so really infrequent um cell
populations
um this is not the day here this is the
one i wanted to share with you all
um so
in this sample we've got pbmcs with a
spike in of 10
uh
cells from a tumor cell line
um and
normally there's quite a few supposed
false positives because our
healthy donors often have a double
positive in this population where we
would expect essentially nothing to be
there but once we come to our imaging
cytometer we can see that in fact most
of uh most of those positives are in
fact debris and other cells that or
or doublets or who knows what is in
there also another nice big reveal is
how dirty our sample prep can be
sometimes once we are able to look at
all these cells in suspension
um
so there should be about 10 tumor cells
in here i'm just going to come through
on this image gallery and select
what i suppose to be these tumor cells
so we have one two three four
five six seven eight
so eight out of ten
pretty good in my opinion
now i have them selected and show them
on the plot and there are my eight cells
so once we actually uh
use our standard duplicating as you
might normally do or maybe you'll just
use this r2 instead
and i actually select the r4 gate you
can see that we actually only have three
cells there but when we look at looked
at all of our images we actually had
eight so we're missing out on five
possible cells
that we
would possibly identify as double
positive
for that population
and if we come to a sample now where
we've spiked in 50 of these cells so we
expect to be double positive on these
two channels here
um you look at your r4 gate again we
have 14 events here
um however when you come to your r6
i won't belabor the point but we did go
through and count these and i think we
had about 48 cells
including lots of debris
this has also helped us become a little
bit more intelligent in our gating i
know to all of you it's quite obvious
that
this is our cluster of positive cells
however
once we start going into actual patient
samples and we are not just looking at
uh tumor cell lines that are nice and
clear that you have a single cell this
will become much more muddy and so we're
in the middle of that that project and
i'm really excited to see how that
develops
that is all i have to share with you
today on the system um i have thoroughly
enjoyed using this for the past three
months
and
we'll continue to use it as as much as
possible we're training new users on the
system so i think we're going to be
getting a lot more interesting data out
of here and i just want to say a special
thank you to the team at thermo fisher
that has let us demo this system um and
built this wonderful instrument that
i've really enjoyed using and uh thank
you for joining me today
[Music]
thank you cora for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
are there any specific steps you have to
take for sample preparation
so this is cora speaking now um
there are no uh special steps that you
need to take for sample preparation in
fact
what i have regularly used this
instrument in the lab for
lately as we're
developing our protocols and how we want
to actually train
researchers and users
on the system is
using the system to
do a small validation with uh with
fixation of samples so we
essentially when i see perhaps what i
suspect to be poor fixation at another
analyzer system i will then take them
over to the site pics
just to
have a quick view of the cells and see
if there is any compromised um
compromised fixation of the samples
so
no there's nothing special that you have
to do with these samples to take these
images
great thank you
next question
what type of cells can be analyzed on
psychics
um
pretty much any type of cell that you
would analyze in a conventional flow
cytometer so bacteria yeast mammalian
cells
anything that you
can collect your traditional scatter and
fluorescence data from you can also
analyze on the system
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question
how easy is it to transition from a
conventional analyzer to site pics
oh very easy it's not even really a
transition
just the extra consideration is
making sure that maybe you have a little
more storage space for the images
because you're not only acquiring those
fcs files but you also have images
attached to those those fcs files
um
[Music]
but other than that there's no special
consideration outside of what you would
normally need to do with a a
conventional flow cytometer so making
sure that the uh you have band pass
filters in front of your pmt's that
actually select the light from your
target floor for um
so exactly the way you would design a
panel and then the other system
hey great thank you
um
it looks like we have time for maybe one
more question
um
i would like to know what next
interesting experiments
they are about to plan to test new
limits of the site picks
if you have any information on that
um i think that is
something that would be
best handled by our
our collaborators at uh thermo fisher
okay
great well thank you
cora do you have any final comments for
our audience
um no just uh thank you for having me
and
like i said in the video i am excited to
continue using the system
great well thank you again cora for your
time today
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor thermo fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye